[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 les
invités nous sommes le 1er décembre une
nouvelle fois nous donnons la parole à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité donc
département et vous entendrez ce soir
gérard bachelier il vient de décrocher
un deuxième mandat de président à la
chambre de commerce versailles yvelines
l'enjeu est important face à la
diminution des aides attribuées par
l'état et puis avec laurence monde ont
chargé de la communication de l'alec la
longeole agence locale de l'énergie et
du climat de 50 ans il sera question du
défit familles à énergie positive chaque
famille participante doit parvenir à une
réduction de 8% de ses consommations
énergétiques
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
versailles yvelines la cci 78 connaît
donc le nom de son président est il
s'agit de gérard bacheliers nouveau
mandat pour le candidat sortant c'est un
monde a acquis devraient être délicat
cette instance est chargée de promouvoir
les entreprises du bassin mais aussi
d'assurer la formation des apprentis
voit ses dotations en forte baisse
rencontre avec gérard bacheliers à
versailles dans les locaux de la cci sur
des images signées patrick jacques de
dixmude gérard bacheliers chef
d'entreprise a donc été reconduit dans
ses fonctions de président de la chambre
de commerce versailles yvelines bonsoir
janvier votre liste est arrivée en tête
dans ce scrutin et vos colistiers ont
choisi de vous renouveler leur confiance
comment vous analysez tout d'abord votre
résultat est cette cette victoire je
pense que la victoire d'où là devant un
travail qui a été réalisé depuis 2013
qui est un travail de proximité
vis-à-vis des entreprises du territoire
et
aussi je pense par une reconnaissance
des grands projets sur lequel on
travaille c'est vrai qu'on parle tout de
même de la participation qui finalement
reste restent assez faibles on l'a
évoqué juste avant le début de cet or
cet enregistrement autour de 4% au
niveau de l'île de france autour de 6%
dans les yvelines
ça reste faible ou 7 acceptable pour
vous c'est 6 77% pour l'est pour les
yvelines
bien sûr ce n'est pas acceptable parce
qu'on souhaiterait que les chefs
d'entreprise à y voter et choisissent
vraiment leurs représentants à la
chambre de commerce
mais je crois que les élections en
général et la chambre de métiers a subi
le même label mêmes difficultés
justement les chefs d'entreprise ne sont
pas là pour nous soutenir suffisamment
et on espère que dans nos actions ils
vont nous soutenir un petit peu plus
parce que du coup ça entraîne un manque
de représentativité aussi pour vous deux
légitimités peut-être est-ce que vous le
personnel comme ça oui bien sûr ça ça
peut être un manque
on peut le voir comme un manque de
légitimité ceci dit entre les 10% qui
aux dernières élections et les 6 77%
actuellement la différence est pas
importante
elles existent sur l'ensemble de la
france puisque toutes les participations
au niveau des cci françaises en baissé
de moitié alors néanmoins même si la
participation était plutôt faible il ya
une campagne malgré tout il y avait
d'autres listes aussi et puis à des
critiques qui ont été formulées
est-ce que vous avez un mot pour vos
adversaires est ce que vous avez entendu
ce qui a pu vous être dit pendant cette
campagne
non je crois que cette période
doit être terminée je crois qu'il vaut
mieux partir parler de l'avenir que du
passé
je ne suis pas quelqu'un de revanchards
et je pense qu'effectivement les
élections on les a gagnés en tout cas la
liste yvelines entreprises la liste est
yes a gagné ces élections mais
maintenant je pense qu'il faut qu'on
travaille tous ensemble et d'ailleurs
dans le bureau qui vient d'être élu
aujourd'hui il ya des élus bien sûr de
l'autre liste ça sera du medef notamment
oui en fait la liste il une entreprise
l'été une liste qui était soutenue par
la cgpme
effectivement mais un certain nombre de
2,2 d'élus qui sont dans cette liste
soit aussi des personnes qui peuvent
être proche du medef pu être proche du
medef à certains moments en tout cas
c'est votre deuxième deuxième mandat à
quelles sont vos priorités à présent les
priorités je crois que ça va être ce
qu'on a essayé de faire depuis 2013
c'est-à-dire d'accentuer la proximité
nos chambres de commerce vis-à-vis du
territoire vis-à-vis des entreprises
allez les voir aller voir les chefs
d'entreprise moi c'est ce que j'ai
toujours demandé aux équipes de notre
chambre de commerce est allé voir les
chefs d'entreprise aller les rencontrer
donc je crois que ça va être pour moi
l'élément essentiel
et puis aussi travailler en partenariat
avec les collectivités quels sont les
inquiétudes pour les entreprises
aujourd'hui justement alors qu'en plus
on entre dans une campagne électorale
pour pour le coup un le scrutin à la
chambre de commerce est terminée mais au
niveau national des élections vont
débuter
j'imagine que les chefs d'entreprise les
chambres de commerce vont vouloir aussi
se faire entendre du futur président
voire des futurs députés
les entreprises souffrent depuis pas mal
d'années quand même sur le territoire et
en particulier au niveau de l'industrie
ont soit un petit frémissement dans le
développement économique actuellement on
sent que ça ça repart un petit peu mais
c'est insuffisant et beaucoup
d'entreprises souffrent donc il ya
effectivement une souffrance de ces de
ses chefs d'entreprise et puis il faut
leur simplifier le travail il faut aussi
qu'au niveau des cotisations sociales
il y en ait un peu moins donc je vais
pas reprendre les thèmes que justement
développe soit le medef sur la cgpme je
crois que ça serait bien effectivement
qu'on allège un petit peu les fardeaux
des chefs d'entreprise c'est le message
que vous allez faire passer pendant la
campagne a créé cci va s'impliquer
pendant cette campagne électorale par
exemple il nous ne sommes pas nous moi
en tant que président de la chambre
départementale
je ne dois pas m'impliquer dans une
campagne électorale passer des messages
mais veulent passer des messages
effectivement et je viens d'en passer un
ou deux mais je crois que je veux pas
être le seul à passer ce type de message
et c'est même message pense que c'est
aussi le rôle des organisations
professionnelles du medef la cgpme de
passer des messages
notre rôle août c'est d'accompagner les
chefs d'entreprises de les aider à se
développer d'accompagner le
développement économique du territoire
aux signes
j'aimerais juste confessionnelles une
parenthèse par rapport aux roues en
public qui nous regardent et qui
peut-être ne saisit pas toute
l'importance d'une chambre de commerce
la mission principale c'est de
l'accompagnement de ces entreprises mais
plus concrètement ça se traduit comment
vous intervenez
tout d'abord la chambre de commerce en
mission sa mission première c'est
d'aider à la création d'entreprise est
la création d'entreprise voire à la
transmission d'entreprise aussi mais ce
qu'ils deviennent moins ce qui était
très important c'est aussi
l'accompagnement des entreprises
on sait que 40% des entreprises qui se
créent disparaissent au bout de trois
ans ont disparu au bout de trois ans
donc ça fait beaucoup d'entreprises qui
disparaissent donc l'accompagnement et
plus appeler est très important et
justement de leur permettre de se
développer de rester de rester valide je
dirais pendant plus d'années que trois
ans est un élément important pour le
développement économique d'un territoire
donc c'est ça c'est accompagné avant
tout les entreprises et est-ce que vous
avez les moyens de vos ambitions tout
simplement parce qu il
réorganisation que le financement des
chambres de commerce aussi reste restant
dossier délicat est ce qu'aujourd'hui il
ya des difficultés réelles les moyens on
a pu suffisamment effectivement c'est à
dire que dans notre chambre
départementale
on a une réduction des effectifs de
moitié
donc ce qui est très important donc on
manque de moyens
la chambre régionale manque de moyens on
manque de moyens pour les écoles et les
écoles c'est important il ya quand même
trente mille étudiants dans les aidant
les 24 écoles de la chambre
quinze mille apprentis tant que sans les
moyens pour justement gérer ces écoles
leur permettent d'investir dans de
nouveaux matériels
je pense que ça aura des effets
effectivement sur l'apprentissage
donc il faut au cours de ce mandat que
vous trouviez des ressources nécessaires
suffit vous qu'on trouve
il faut qu'on trouve des ressources il
faut qu'on essaie de effectivement que
l'état nous aide un peu plus que que là
le conseil régional nous est que toutes
les structures territoriales nous aident
et aussi les communautés de communes
puisque la relation avec les communautés
de communes est importante dans le
développement économique du territoire
une chambre de commerce sans les
communautés de communes et communautés
de communes sans les chambres de
commerce
je pense que ça ne peut pas marcher mais
malgré tout les communautés de communes
les agglomérations qui prennent de plus
en plus à leur charge le développement
économique aussi par exemple je pense à
saint quentin en yvelines qui met
l'accent depuis quelques temps sur le
développement économique par exemple est
ce qu'il n'ya pas un doublon une
concurrence entre vous et d'une mission
d agglomération c'est une mission
importante des des communautés de
communes
j'apprécie d'ailleurs qu'ils aient cette
mission parce qu'effectivement leur
territoire est important il faut aussi
qu'ils s'intéressent bien sûr au
développement économique
ce que je regrette c'est qu'il crée
effectivement des équipes qui sont
concurrentes des équipes de la chambre
de commerce
il est bien dommage qu'on n'ait pas la
possibilité de travailler en synergie
avec les communautés de communes et que
la chambre de commerce puis justement
apporter ses services aux communautés de
communes pour le développement
économique
donc aujourd'hui vouloir tendez la main
vous appeler au dialogue j'appelle au
dialogue sans arrêt les communautés de
communes je pense qu'il ya une volonté
effectivement de rentrer fortement dans
ce développement économique de se
l'attribuer ce qui est très positif
simplement évitant de créer une feuille
supplémentaire dans le mille feuilles en
créant des nouvelles équipes
effectivement dans les communautés de
communes pour le développement
économique la chambre de commerce est là
pour le faire merci gérard bacheliers
donc président de cette cci pour ce
second mandat
[Musique]
et pour la suite de ce set 8 les invités
je reçois présents sur ce plateau
laurence mon bonsoir vous est elle
chargée de la communication de l l'alec
lagence de locale de l'énergie et du
climat sur saint quentin en yvelines
yvelines sud nous allons parler avec
vous de cette opération familles à
énergie positive avec un principe plutôt
simple c'est réduire la consommation des
ménages il faudra réduire de 8% c'est la
barre qui a été fixée alors avant de
nous expliquer comment on peut réduire
tout ça pourquoi cette barre de 8% qui
est fixée pour ces familles alors oui
pour cent parce que la france dans le
cadre du protocole de kyoto a s'est
engagé à réduire de l'ue pour cent ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre par
rapport aux niveaux d'émissions de 1990
donc là le principe c'est que les
familles s'inscrivent elles peuvent
encore s'inscrire c'est à débuter à
partir du 26 novembre et ensuite vous
voulez les inciter à réduire leur
consommation alors comment on peut
réduire sa facture sur une année de vie
pour cent par rapport à l'année
précédente
alors c'est par des écogestes c'est à
dire qu' il n'est pas question
d'investir dans la changement d'une
chaudière ou bien dans l'isolation de la
toiture n'est vraiment sûr des éco
gestes et puis j'ai ce qu'on peut faire
à la maison
ça ne coûte rien on peut réduire la
facture sans investir voilà ou alors des
petits investissements
ça va être par exemple des mousseurs
qu'on va mettre sur les robinets
voilà des vraiment dès tout petit
investissement comme des mais également
des multiprises interrupteur comme
d'habitude parce qu'ils avaient alors là
ce système là c'est autre chose c'est
autre chose en vente par les accords
elle a du coup voilà c'est vraiment sur
ce principe là en sachant que c'est sans
perte de confort parce que les familles
au bout d'un moment vont se lasser même
ne vont même pas s'engager et
et voilà 8 % tout en s'amusant donc
l'objectif c'est se mettre en équipe ont
fait bien des économies d'énergie à la
maison mais en équipe donc 3 à un
collègue annie fonctionner par équipes
donc voilà s'associe avec son voisin on
s'associe pas forcément dans le même
immeuble
vous voilà on fait des équipes de
combien entre cinq et dix familles 5 et
10 famille et chacun doit jouer le jeu
donc il doit y avoir une certaine
émulation pour justement incité ses amis
collègues à faire pareil et à la fin à
la faim le remporter ça sent bon le
sachant que ça se déroule dans tout ce
territoire yvelines sud et que le
verdict un les résultats seront donnés à
partir du mois de mai ça va courir
jusqu'au mois d'avril
voilà la compétition jo revient quand
même à ce petit objet ça consiste en
quoi alors cet objet c'est un objet qui
va justement aider les familles chaque
équipe aura différents types vous voulez
emprunter
oui bien sûr voilà chaque équipe aura
aura différents outils de manière à
mesurer ses consommations d'énergie à la
maison donc ça celui ci fait partie de
la malade c'est un wattmètre qui me
permet de mesurer la consommation
d'énergie des appareils électriques à la
maison dans la mallette il ya également
un thermomètre et gourmette il ya
également un thermomètre de surface un
débitmètre etc plusieurs outils qui vont
permettre aux familles d'accéder fonde
d'identifier là où sont leurs
consommations pour pouvoir ensuite agir
en adaptant les éco gestes qu'il faut
c'est un objet qui coûte cher c'est pas
un objet qui coûte cher en acceptant le
petit investissement et avoir ensuite
faire de l'économie des économies au
quotidien ces fameux kiwi celui ci est
prêté en fait pas tant qu'indépendant le
cadre du défi pour pour ces familles
justement vous les aidez au delà de ce
prélat mais vous les aidez vous leur
donnez des conseils pour qu'elle
réussisse un peu tout à fait on est
chargé donc de l'accompagnement des
familles parce que nous aussi on veut
réussir le défi sur le sud du
département débuts pour son drake tous
les équipes qui arrivent donc pour cela
il ya par exemple guide des 100 éco
gestes qui va permettre aux familles
après avoir identifié ou et leur
consommation est bien de choisir les
cogest qui sera le plus adapté pour les
éco gestes qui seront les plus adaptées
à leur consommation
et puis ben parfois on commence par un
ou deux éco gestes et puis au fur et à
mesure du défi qui dure cinq mois on va
avoir l'occasion de tester plusieurs s
concerne justement des familles il ya
une émulation avec les plus jeunes
sensibiliser les adultes qui sont
peut-être moins sensibilisés pour le
coup oui voilà les enfants participent
énormément les petits outils de mesure à
la maison aide aussi justement à ce
qu'il prenne conscience dire aux parents
n'avaient pas fait les bonnes choses on
geste on réduire les consommations
d'énergie
les résultats qui sont obtenues
justement par rapport aux précédentes
éditions çà ça vraiment fonctionné ce
défi des 8% étaient remplies par la
plupart des femmes non il ya 80% des
familles en france il ya 80% des
familles qui réussissent le défi donc
une fois qu'on s'inscrit on a toutes les
chances de réussir ce défi l'on gagne
quoi à part des économies d'énergie
alors les économies d'énergie il faut
pas à ces pannes et déjà vu pour cent ça
représente à peu près de 100 euros sur
la facture annuelle donc ce qui permet
ensuite de partir en vacances au mois de
juin juillet août
voilà avec un budget supplémentaire on
peut donc vous l'avez dire encore encore
s'inscrire il suffit de vous contacter
les noms adresses mail qui va s'afficher
voilà tout à fait aussi simple que ça
puis sur le site internet défi famille
paisible énergie positive
une toute dernière question une famille
qui veut s'inscrire qu'il n'a pas
forcément de collègues ou de voisins
avec qui participez vous avez des
familles à proposer des groupes ont il
ya des familles à proposer on peut
s'inscrire aussi individuellement mais
c'est vrai que c'est plus sympa d'être
en équipe et pouvoir partager ses
astuces parce qu'on a tous des choses à
partager et des petits éco geste qu'on
connaît déjà et qu'on applique aucune
excuse pour ne pas participer à cette
opération pour la planète et pour le
porte monnaie aussi merci d'être venu me
parler de cette opération familles à
énergie positive et puis bien sûr on
viendra voir leurs résultats que vous
avez obtenus peut-être faire un point
d'étape aussi dans les prochaines
semaines merci à vous c'est la fin du
28e les invités pour ce soir prochaine
édition ce sera à l'andi d'ici là nous
replays sont à consulter sur le site
internet travel soirée
[Musique]